on Sunday night Taylor Swift debuted her
music video for delicate at the
iHeartRadio Music Awards I would have
preferred a music video for dancing with
her hand side but delegate will have to
do because Taylor Swift is Taylor Swift
and the Internet is the Internet it
didn't take long before fans started
finding or maybe making up Easter eggs a
few eagle-eyed viewers spotted a
reference hidden in the subway sequence
it said track five on a pillar the song
is the fifth track on reputation a lot
of fans pointed out the clear reference
to singing in the rain while others
called out the music video for
potentially ripping off this perfume at
and literally just one person has
pointed out the similarities to the 1960
Italian film Laden Chara but perhaps the
most obvious references are to our
British boyfriend Joe Allen for example
the song has lyrics like oh damn never
seem that blue color and you guessed it
geo has blue eyes queen of metaphors
other references are a little bit more
subtle like the ones seen here way in
the background you can see a sign for
Joe's deli and Twitter user Taylor's
cookies cue Twitter named tbh points out
that Swift spells out j OE while she
dances though if you play out the video
there are a few other letters that
Taylor's cookies left out so unless
Taylor was trying to write out LJ OTE
this theory might just be a coincidence
sorry Taylor's cookies other connections
are a little bit harder to deny the
Washington Post speculates that delicate
is the answer to the question where has
Taylor been and why she becomes
invisible at the start of the video on
the red carpet someone slips her a
glittery note which the lyrics tell us
read dive bar on the east side where you
at Twitter user Reagan Burton and the
number of other fans speculate that Joe
is the one who hands her the note and I
speculate that Taylor Swift has never
been to a dive bar after Taylor reads
the note poof she's invisible she's only
seen at the end of the video by people
we guess are her friends it's not a far
stretch to imagine that Taylor's message
in this video is that she wants to
retreat from the public eye and enjoy
her relationships in secret or maybe she
just really loves that movie how
man starring Kevin Bacon who's to say
I'm sure we're just starting to scratch
the surface of all the little hidden
details that are hidden in the video but
it just goes to show you that whenever
Taylor Swift posts anything anywhere the
entire world is watching some more
intently than others
[Music]